Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom.
Feel what it's like to be Indiana Jones.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Sean.
I'm Joe.
And I'm Sam.
Guys, thank you all for joining me today in what is sure to be a blockbuster of an episode.
Am I right? Like the place you go to rent movies.
The place you used to go.
To rent Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom.
Yeah. I still go.
We should probably talk about the movie before we ever talk about the game
because this is one of those things that I don't ever associate with George Lucas, but I guess you should.
He wants you to know he's very responsible for Indiana Jones.
I only ever watched the first one.
I never felt like this was the trilogy I needed to be a part of.
So when it came to Temple of Doom and Last Crusade and the one where he goes inside a fridge, like I don't really think I need to watch those movies.
You know, I actually really liked The Last Crusade.
I saw that one. The first one's still the best, but The Last Crusade I thought was pretty good.
Which one's The Last Crusade?
That's the third one with Sean Connery.
Oh, interesting. I mean, I don't remember it.
I haven't seen it in a long time, but I remember liking it a lot.
Now that I think about it, I started watching it with my friend in March or in February.
It was right before COVID and then we just both lost interest.
We watched something else. Temple of Doom or Last Crusade?
Last Crusade. Okay.
Maybe it doesn't hold up.
Maybe I'm idealizing it.
So is Temple of Doom the second one?
The second one.
Yes. Okay. Yeah.
Which is a thing that we get often on this show.
Somehow the NES released like right in the middle of all of these franchises coming out.
Thankfully, we got a game based off of the original Jaws and not Jaws 2, but we got Karate Kid 2.
We got Goonies 2 and that didn't even like ever come out.
We have Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom.
So, you know, I don't know what it is, but I guess you just, it makes sense to be like whatever the actual movie is.
Let's sell the hype towards that rather than like the big one that everyone knows.
Yeah. I also, I don't know the actual plot to Temple of Doom because I, the one that I read in the manual for this game doesn't seem to be all that in depth.
Could you give the spark notes to us?
Uh, you gotta go save some children.
Uh, and then there's a big fight on a bridge, uh, against a dude.
Yeah. I don't know his name, but.
Oh, so you've seen the movie.
I didn't see the movie, no.
Oh, it sounds like you did.
I'm just kidding. How much of the movie, Joe, has to do with rescuing children who are forced into slavery?
To be honest, I really don't remember.
I remember because Temple of Doom, Temple of Doom I only saw once.
And, uh, I just remember a couple things when I was a kid that sort of disturbed me.
I remember there being eyeballs in a bowl of soup and that, that freaked me out.
Um, I, I don't even remember specifics.
I just remember there was just, there was some disturbing imagery for, for my child brain.
Is it the one where there's like a, where, where they have that shot battle where like Indiana Jones takes a bunch of shots with somebody?
Or maybe that's a different one and.
Like, like drinking shots.
Drinking shots, like in a bar.
Cause I thought you were talking about the one where the guy like whips around the sword and then Indy's just like,
I'll just shoot you.
I have a gun. Oh, that's, that's, that's a great scene.
We are, we are basically experts on the Indiana Jones franchise.
Yeah. I hope there's not like a listener.
That's just a huge Indiana Jones fan.
That's like just pulling their hair out right now.
Yeah. I would hope they're not pulling out their hair because this is a very authentic experience they're getting.
They're getting four people who could care less about Indiana Jones about to do a deep dive into it.
But I do think that's important though, right?
Like kids who grew up in the late seventies, early eighties were probably huge Indiana Jones fans as a result of like, you know, they, they just kind of missed out on star Wars.
Like they were probably way too young for that.
And so I feel like Indiana Jones and back to the future are like the three, the two big trilogies of that, you know, that late eighties style thing.
Maybe, I don't know. The, the Terminator probably comes a little bit later in terms of trilogy, but that's like what I think of when I think of like late eighties trilogies is Indiana Jones.
And, um, the other one I just said, the other one I just said, that's the future.
When did, when did the first one come out?
Are you going to confirm it for us, Joe?
Or I'm looking right now.
I'm trying to remember what the first one was called.
What was it called? The Raiders of the Lost Ark.
The Oakland Raiders of the Lost Ark.
Do you feel like you have to call the first movie of a trilogy or of a series in general?
Do you feel like you have to call that one by its subtitle or do you think you can get away with just saying Indiana Jones, Star Wars?
I mean, I just call it Star Wars one.
Um, which is wrong.
He specifically numbered them.
He numbered them on purpose.
By the way, it's 1981.
Oh, so this is one of those things where like it took a long time to get to Temple of Doom.
Sounds like it. Yeah.
Cause Temple of Doom was like 85, I believe.
Yeah, 84. Oh man, I'm all over the place.
Anyway, we should probably talk about video games cause we should stick to what we know.
Uh, all four of us in one way or another work in media.
So it's really upsetting that we don't know anything about Indiana Jones, but.
He's played by Harrison Ford.
That's, that's good to know.
Um, he's played by Harrison Ford.
He has a hat he likes very much.
He doesn't like snakes.
What do you call that hat? It's got a name.
Or what? His hat?
The hat's got a name. Yeah.
It's like a fedora, right? Not like a pet name.
Yeah, not a pet name.
Like a, is it Stetson?
It's a fedora.
Fedora? What?
It's a neckbeard fedora.
Harrison Ford's a neckbeard.
You heard it. Harrison fedora.
All right. Video game wise though, Indiana Jones and the temple of doom is another one of those unlicensed
then licensed Tenjin Atari games that they got like sued like crazy for by Nintendo.
You guys don't need me to recap this story anymore, right?
Um, I, I believe we've gone over it, right?
Yeah. No, three times now.
This is like, you know, RBI baseball had it.
Um, what was another one that had it?
Uh, just did it.
We just did a big one on it, but a Pac-Man, Pac-Man had the problem.
So Atari keeps trying to do this thing under a second company called Tenjin and it's just
not working out.
And what's funny is, is we're finally playing temple of doom, but it took a long time to do
time for this version of the game to get to NES players because the film comes out in 84.
The arcade game comes out in 1985.
The arcade game is then ported to a bunch of other like computer systems in like 86.
Finally comes unlicensed to the, uh, NES by Tenjin in like early 1988.
And then everybody's like, no, no, no, you can't do that.
So mindscape, another company releases the licensed version of temple of doom from Atari
in December of 88.
So, you know, from 84, 85 and 84, if you count the film all the way till now, it's been in
the making, but it's like, finally you can play Indiana Jones and the temple of doom on
your NES. And I'm just not sure how many people were looking for that.
Yeah. It's actually so, so strange to think about because obviously like in the future there,
you know, the games would have released sometimes before the movie, like to, to capitalize on
the hype. Now it's just like, Oh, that was, that was four or five years ago.
It's like a coordinated marketing strategy, uh, in like the nineties and the two thousands.
But, uh, yeah, this just seems like, like, Oh, what if, what if we made an Indiana Jones
game? Uh, I guess like a, I don't even know.
Like what's a movie released four years ago.
That would be weird to get like a port or like a, uh, a video game adaptation of now.
Venom. Yeah. The movie Venom, the movie Tom Hardy.
Yeah. That would be fun.
No, I'd, I'd play a Venom game.
Why not? I, you kind of did in ultimate Spider-Man on PlayStation two.
If anybody played that, you can play as Venom inserted.
Wow. They came out with the game, like a decade before the movie.
It's advanced marketing.
Yeah. They're just priming us right away on booting it up.
It's, it's on my shit list and I'm sure you can, you can understand why.
I'd like to hear it from you.
Well, you start the game by pressing the start button.
The game tells you that much.
It says push, push, start, you know, you push start the Indiana Jones music, which is
beautifully translated from, um, the score that we all know so well.
It's now done, you know, really well on the NES.
Problem is, is that you push start to begin the music, but you don't actually start the
game. Yeah.
And then you press start again.
We are on the same page there.
Yeah. You push start again and nothing happens.
And then you're like, oh, it's one of those games where you press a instead.
And then you press a and nothing happens.
And then you start looking for the shoulder buttons.
You're like, are there shoulder buttons on an NES?
Like what's going on?
And eventually you realize, no, it's the select button.
So it's really push.
You would go to the shoulder buttons before the select button.
And start. No, of course not.
I will say the select button was the last thing I pressed.
I mean, that makes sense, I guess.
No, I don't understand.
I don't understand what the meaning behind that was.
I, it's sort of a thing that continues to happen throughout the game.
Uh, or just boot.
It seems to boot you back to the start screen, but different.
And you have to press select to go into the next level.
I don't, I don't know what this was for, but it's really getting off on the wrong foot.
I think it's trying to prime you into realizing, oh, there's going to be some puzzle elements to this.
The first puzzle is your controller.
Yeah. You guys know that I hate, um, games that make you do inputs that do not matter.
Uh, what was that one recently, Sean?
The, the hockey game blades of steel where you have to press a twice just to actually get into the match.
I have a big pet peeve with this.
So this game wasn't about to get away with it.
If we can talk about the actual game though, you know, bad start menu aside, Indiana Jones, the temple of doom.
It basically, you, you are Indiana and, uh, or Indy as I guess people call him.
And you have to make your way through the temple in a series of 12 levels or waves as they might call them in the game.
They always say wave one, wave two.
I don't think of them like that.
Cause it's not quite like a shmup.
It's just a action adventure game.
Uh, you go throughout these temples and you have to like find a bunch of children and then they leave you like scraps, like guns and blades and keys.
And then you collect those things and you're just trying to collect, round up all the children and get the key and hopefully acquire enough equipment so that you can continue to progress through the game.
Yeah. I mean, it's a pretty standard, uh, loop there.
Uh, one thing that I'll note is, uh, on one of those, uh, press select to actually start the game screens.
It, it, it does give you a very brief rundown of what you're supposed to do.
Um, I think my, my favorite line, uh, like it was like a subtitle sort of thing is that told you how to play was a touch child to get prize.
You know, I wasn't going to say anything, but that jumped out at me also.
No, I had to bring it up.
I think by you saying that the podcast is now on a list.
We're on a list. Yeah.
Touch child. And everyone listening.
Oh, you can put that on a t-shirt.
No, but it is funny though, right?
Cause the whole aspect of the game is collecting these children up.
And I think we joked about this in the pre-show with Sam about how like you're collecting the children, but then they just kind of disappear.
There's no like, there's no insurance that they're going to a better place.
It's like, it's really more like hide and seek than you rescuing the children.
You found them and now you leave.
They give you a knife or a gun as the child does usually.
And then they just run away.
This was the whole thing.
I said you're collecting children and you said, no, no, no, you're saving the children.
Um, right, right.
I don't know.
You know, there's no way to tell what your character is actually doing.
These children are wanted dead or alive is I think the underlying statement here.
Indy seems like a good guy.
So he definitely is saving these kids.
Sean, you brought up the weirdest point though.
So you save the kid and you walk away and then like a, uh, you know, let's say a sword appears.
Right. And you're like, Oh, gotta get the sword.
You pick up the sword.
You walk away. Another sword appears.
You pick up that sword and then you walk away.
And then it's like, Oh, one more sword.
And I'm just like, what is happening?
You'd think these kids could fend for themselves in there.
It's just funny. Yeah.
They didn't have a way to like make the like, Oh, there's three swords in this pickup.
You gained three swords. You have to pick one up, walk away, pick another one up, walk away, pick another one up.
Although I do have to say the walking is very smooth.
Not the jumping or anything else.
The walking itself.
He walks like he's pooping his pants.
No, I, I agree, Sam.
I feel like with the, you know, with the exception of the weird, uh, like perspective of this game, it looks nice.
It looks, the way he walks, the way it animates looks clean compared to a lot of other games we've played.
Okay. I will, I will concede that Indiana Jones as a sprite looks fine and he looks fine.
But if we're going to talk about the controls of this game, like it, I think that we can't just stop at like, Oh, he moves slow.
Oh, he, he moves smoothly in one direction.
I didn't say moves. I said walks.
Big difference. Yeah.
We're just talking about the look of it.
Aesthetically. I thought we were talking about the smoothness.
No, I mean, I mean the smoothness of the, of the animation, the smoothness, the animation
and the motion of the walking part.
That's it. Not the jumping, not anything else.
Just walking around.
I felt was very smooth.
Okay. That's what I, that's what I got.
And I'll just rebut that.
I think it's worth mentioning that the way that his sprite is designed, it looks like
he has taken a dump in his pants and he needs to like, like he's kind of like cowboy walking
his way through.
It was a smooth. Well, Indiana Jones is historically bow legged.
So you're just making fun of a, like a disability in a way.
So I, yeah, that's insensitive of me.
Yeah. Very insensitive.
Do you want to talk about how you move around this game?
No. Well, I think I know I do.
I do. And I think that the most important thing that was brought up was the confusing perspective
because you got this like straight top down view of everything.
However, the game is more like, want you to think of everything in a 2.5 D kind of
way in the sense that like the, the cave has, uh, multiple different layers of hills, if
you will, that stack upon each other.
So you can't quite like you're jumping down to other things.
I don't know. It's very hard to explain the perspective.
No, it doesn't.
It's so I can explain it.
Please. Uh, the game is, is stuck between deciding whether, uh, the up, the top portion of your
screen and the bottom portion of your screen are above and below something, or if it's
in front or behind, because, uh, it does, it does sort of allow you to jump down, but
it, it, it's more treating it as if the things that you're jumping across or over are, are
just like right in front of you.
Like if you're going to jump over something and it's like lava, you would think that you're
going to jump over the lava, but no, you fall into the lava and you die.
So it's, it's like a, an MC Escher sort of feeling.
It's very, just it's, it's very, uh, discombobulating.
Um, I don't think I ever got it right.
Um, cause some things you can and cannot jump over, it treats it as above and below or in
front and behind. I hate it.
Um, I guess it is kind of hard to describe.
It's just broken.
It's a broken perspective.
It doesn't really make any sense.
If you look really closely and use your imagination, you can like see what they want, what they
meant. Like, like I can see now when I'm like looking at it and say, okay, I guess they were trying
to make this look like this was a flat platform and this texture was the wall, but they, they
missed, I don't, I'm not an artist, but they missed out on like doing something with the angles
of the flat platforms to make them look like they're perpendicular to the wall.
Well, neither were they. Everything looks flat.
It's almost like a child's drawing where perspective is always confused and some things are shown
at an angle and some things are shown flat, uh, like straight on.
Um, it, it, none of it is like, you can get their logic, but it's not, it's not cohesive
along the entire level, like within the level.
Right. It's definitely not intuitive.
Yeah. You know how, like when you look at a world map and if you didn't know any better about
the earth, right? Let's say you didn't know anything about the earth.
You could think that the water are the continents and that the continents are the ocean, right?
Like you could invert it in your, in your mind.
If you didn't know enough, that was me going into temple of doom.
When the game first started, I actually thought that like the walls were what I was supposed
to be walking on and that like what the ground was, was not what I was supposed to be walking
towards. And I was like, why can't I move?
Like my character is just locked to, uh, to these directions.
And I know that sounds crazy, but it is actually something that happened to me for like one
and a half seconds where I was genuinely confused at the startup of this game being like, where
do I walk to?
Yeah. The thing that got me was that I, after a little bit, I kind of understood like, all
right, there's different layers of this.
You can jump down onto the other layer, but you really can't jump horizontally like over
a gap or anything.
You kind of jump down and to the right.
Yeah. When you're in, especially in that, um, like the mine cart area.
Um, I was like trying to jump from one area to the right.
And instead my guy just jumps down like 30 feet and falls into lava.
Yeah. That's always the most unsettling thing.
Cause the lava again, looks like, it looks like in a legend of Zelda game where there's
just lava is far away in front of you or behind you.
But then like, imagine if in that legend of Zelda game, you, you, you moved a little bit
and suddenly you just zoomed to the lava because it's trying to tell you you're falling, but
it looks like you're just zooming over the ground.
It doesn't feel logical.
And even if you jump what you think is over the lava, but you may clip another, uh, you
may clip another like sprite of lava that's supposedly above you, you're basically jumping
into that as well.
And then you die. Um, and so that that's again, another point of just like, they're, they're not, it's not
logically cohesive.
You're, you're jumping above and into something, even though it's a, but I don't know.
Yeah. What this game definitely needed was like a pass through the, um, the current 3d NES
emulator that exists online.
Uh, I think everybody has to like manually make those, like tell them what is what for
depth, but it's really cool to see games like super Mario brothers and Mega Man in like
this 3d, uh, aspect of course you can't roam back and forth, but I'd like to see somebody
take a stab at like Indiana Jones, the temple of doom in this 3d NES emulator just to see
if they could actually define for people what those things are supposed to look like.
Cause I agree. It's confusing of what's a pitfall.
What's something you should actually walk across.
The conveyor belts are also like on a flat plane, but should clearly be acting more like
ladders or, or something, you know, but then there are ladders that they don't have the
same angle as the conveyor belts.
It's all very strange.
And you have your little whip jump.
You can do too. I would imagine that the 3d emulated version of this would look like some sort of a like
optical illusion where something is always in front of the other.
And like, it just sort of a mind fuck it.
It wouldn't work. I don't think that it would, it would work.
Well, Sean, you mentioned very early on about the jump and I think we've all been dying to
talk about this.
So, you know, Sean, why don't you lead this charge and explain to the listeners at home
why the jump isn't quite working in this game?
Well, it's, it, it, it very much ties into what we've been talking about.
Um, if you just, if you're trying to jump up somewhere, you're most likely going to be
jumping down. I think if you hold up while you jump, you, you have a better chance of landing in the
same, like, like on, on the same like level that you want.
Like it's a little bit easier that way.
Um, but otherwise it, it, it just, it doesn't go where you want it to go.
Um, that, that's really all I have to say about the jump.
No, you're right. It's a directional pad thing.
You have to put the, the D pad input in with your jump.
So you have to already be holding down on like the left or right or the up on the D pad
before confirming your jump.
Because if you try to do them at the same time, it'll most likely just make you jump
down. Um, but overall it's not, it's not that it's confusing.
It's that the jump itself too, isn't, um, isn't this great mechanic that allows you to
like easily get over, um, obstacles and lava pits and stuff like that.
There are these little spikes in the ground that pop up and down and they're caught.
They're common obstacles in a video game of this day and age.
They'll hit you even if you're jumping.
They'll hit you even if you're jumping, which is weird.
But then there's also like the jump doesn't really jump that far over them.
So there's a good chance your jump is also just going to land you right in those, uh,
spike pits. Yeah.
It's all, I almost feel like the jump is like, it's really only there to get you from
like one platform, quote unquote, to a lower platform because like, you can't really use
it for anything else. And even if you're trying to, you'll probably just end up falling to a lower platform.
It's definitely not using the jump as a platformer would.
Right. Yeah.
In the minecart sections, don't they just repeat in every direction?
So if you keep going down, won't you eventually kind of restart?
And if you keep going right...
Assuming there's no lava below you, yes.
There are dead ends in which you will die of fear in the minecart,
and there are caves that you go into that'll move you into a different screen.
Right. So I don't know if you could just stay on one forever and keep repeating.
But that is a part of the game that makes it feel even more like an MC Escher mindfuck,
is that I didn't notice this because I just started walking to the right,
and I kept walking to the right, and I thought, like, oh, this level just repeats.
But no, it's a torus.
You just keep going in the same direction.
I think it does the same thing if you go down also.
Yeah, I think it loops in every direction with no, like,
at least in some Mario levels, in Mario 3,
some of them you'll loop,
but you see yourself come across the other end of the screen,
whereas this is just, like,
there's no, like, indication that you've looped.
So you're just like, wait a minute, am I already back at the beginning?
Does this look familiar? This is like that level in Super Mario 1
where you're in the castle,
and you have to, like, go through the...
You know what I'm talking about?
I think it's, like, at the end of 8.4 or something.
Yeah, you're talking about, like, 8.4, yep.
Well, it's kind of like that, Sam,
but the only difference here is, like,
imagine if, and as soon as you got to the bottom,
you just miraculously spawned up to the top.
Yeah. And, you know, I'm kind of conflicted about that
because sometimes that actually helped me, like,
unlock a key on how to save a particular kid
or how to progress to, like, a different part of the stage
that I couldn't figure out otherwise.
Sometimes just, like, understanding of, like,
spatial awareness, I guess,
of, like, where you are in the stage
really helped, actually, by that.
So I wouldn't ask them to just, like, lock these levels
so that once you go, like, as far down as possible,
the screen stops moving
and you have to now, like, progress back up
because I think it helped me kind of figure out, like,
no, I'm repeating, I'm going in circles,
like, I need to try maybe going to the left
or maybe try jumping over one of these things
or using my whip.
It allowed you to realize your mistake.
Yeah. I mean, I think that that mechanic is fine.
It's more just the lack of any, like, indication
that you've looped that felt really weird to me.
I don't know what that would be, I guess,
but it was just, I guess, at first was very confusing
and not clear that that was going to happen.
I guess if it's, like, between this and something,
like, what was it, like, the Lode Runner sequel or...
What about Lode Runner?
Was it Lode Runner or was it,
what was the one where you're in the giant cave
that is just enormous?
Super Pitfall?
Super Pitfall, that's it.
Not Lode Runner. I knew it was something like that.
If it was between this and Super Pitfall,
I would go this kind of thing
because you really grow to understand
the area that you're in.
Is Super Pitfall sort of a loop like this?
No, no, I'm saying it doesn't.
No, no, no, he's saying if you have to choose between the two.
Yeah, if I had to choose between
some huge, expansive area that I could,
that I had to, like, if I knew I had to get back to a certain part of it,
I had to go all the way back,
or this where I knew it would just repeat,
then I'd prefer this.
So I think that I'm kind of, like,
on the same page as you, Mike,
where it does seem kind of clever and interesting
as a way of understanding the map,
but still disorienting.
I feel like it would, for me,
it would depend on what the game is trying to do.
I do think that this is a cool mechanic
if you kind of build some puzzles around it.
I don't know that they necessarily did.
I think some maybe accidentally worked that way.
But I think that, like,
a one-screen giant map could also be cool
if your goal is to, like,
have people remember the spaces
that they found things,
and, you know, I don't know.
I think that that just depends on
what they're trying to do.
No, you're absolutely right there, Joe,
because I think what I'm trying to get at, too,
is, like, I figured out how to do new things
because of this warping mechanic of the level
in a sense of, like,
probably something that they gave on this position.
Like, I could actually jump over to this thing
and, you know, I might land on the next cliff down
or something instead of, you know,
using the whip to get over
or if there was supposed to be a key
I was supposed to get or something.
So I don't think it was intentional at all.
Yeah, yeah. I mean, this is totally just a silly theory by me,
but I almost, like,
I could see it being the case that, like,
what if they just, they realized, like,
wait a minute, like, man, our controls kind of suck
for getting back up places,
but you know what a good solution for that is?
Let's just have it all loop
so you can always get back to the top
by going to the bottom
rather than, like, fixing the controls.
Who knows if that's what really happened,
but I like that story.
It's funny that, like,
this is the second game in a couple weeks now
that has a whip as a mode of transportation
or sort of like the grappling hook
in Bionic Commando.
It's sort of the same thing
except it feels much jankier.
The way that it's designed, right,
of, like, how to use that
to, like, swing across platforms
and stuff like that.
In Bionic Commando,
you had to kind of give a sense of momentum
and it was clear on what the arm
could latch onto and stuff like that.
I'm not saying that they didn't make it clear
because they did design an object
to, like, register as, like,
you swing onto this.
That's your grapple.
But it blends into the walls itself
to the point where, like,
I saw it in the manual,
but until I actually, like,
recognized it myself in the game,
I didn't know that, like,
it was there. And then, you know,
it happens fairly early on in the game,
but I'm like, oh, yeah, I have to, like,
use my whip to get across.
And because there's no actual architecture
to these levels, they're just a mess,
like a mess of maze-like corridors
and whatever this 2D space is,
there's no context to tell you
that, like, it would even be there
or that this is a thing
that you can traverse over.
Like, it's not, you don't know if it's a wall
or if it's an open gap.
So it took me a while
to recognize those as well.
Speaking of the whip, though,
I would like to talk about the whip combat
because I think it's kind of interesting
because you can't kill someone with the whip.
You can kind of stun them for a second,
but you can keep stunning them
until you push them into lava,
which as far as I could tell
is the only way to kill someone.
Well, the weapons.
I mean, with the whip. Kill someone with the whip.
That's true. I actually noticed using the whip
because it was,
like, the select for the weapon
weapons is kind of weird
and I don't think I ever needed it
because I didn't really get that far,
but I'd gone. Well, Sean, here's the issue.
It's another, it's another input problem for me, okay?
You can only select weapons
while you're in the actual action
adventure environment, right?
Yeah. So, like, enemies are coming at you.
Let's say,
there is not a scenario in the game,
in my opinion, because I did play most of this game,
but there is not a scenario
where you need to actually use a gun,
but it will automatically kill an enemy,
which is useful, right?
Yeah. So let's say you're in a position
where you need to use your gun,
but you don't have it equipped.
The enemy comes towards you
at a speed faster than Indy can walk.
You then need to take your hand off.
Yeah. Yeah, take your hand off
of one side of the controller,
move your, that, let's say your right thumb
to the select button,
move, keep your other thumb where it is,
but toggle through
the other weapons
using the left and right D-pad,
all while the action is still happening.
So you actually have to, like,
move your hands
and watch these enemies
come closer to you
as you toggle through
your weapon selections.
I don't like that choice.
I think this should have been done
through the menus. I mean,
I agree that it could have been done
through the menus, but also I don't think it's
the worst choice to say
you have to do it in real time
because that's the way
it would work in real life.
You have to, you know, Indiana Jones can't pause time
to select things.
I think that the problem
just solely comes from
the weird placement of the buttons
you have to hit together.
Like, there's not a lot of choices
on the NES, but at least if they had chosen
start instead of select,
you could keep your hand
in the same position, hold start,
and select a weapon
rather than having to
literally shift your hands
and then your hand's not on the button
you need to use to use the weapon
and that's a whole mess.
Well, on the same topic
of the pickups
and items
and not so much
on the mechanic of changing between them,
I know that, like,
there were secret rooms
that you needed TNT to open.
I didn't find any TNT,
but I kept finding
those arrows that pointed to where
the secret room was.
Do you, like,
was I just bad
at finding these things?
Or, when was the first level
that you found TNT?
Well, to be honest,
I don't know what the first level
you can actually find TNT is.
It might be, like, hidden as well
in those early levels
because I never found them,
but it is something you can find
throughout the game.
You bring up a good point,
though, with these secret doors
because they are, like,
a kind of a cool feature
of, like, a cave, right?
To have, like, secrets that jump you
to certain points
and you can do certain things
and it seems like
such a simple concept,
but the levels
only get larger
and, you know,
ammo in general,
like, is scarce, right?
Like, you're talking about this TNT.
So, even, say,
if you knew, like, the arrow
for the older ones,
right? If you don't know
where the secret location is
and it's not like it's a dead giveaway
based on that arrow,
you just have a general idea
of the direction, you can't really,
it's not like, you know,
we always use this analogy
of Legend of Zelda spamming all the bushes
to find the one
that you go into the cave,
right? But in that scenario,
you know, your ammo isn't limited.
Like, you actually could take
the time to burn
every bush. Here,
you don't have the time
or the, you know,
like, the risk versus reward
sense to, like,
be like, I'll just bomb
all these walls, one of them's gonna
open up a secret passage.
Yeah. So,
I mean, it just seems like
another half-baked,
half-baked idea
because if you're going
to put it in the first level
and you're not going to give me at least
one piece of TNT
to start, like,
I'm just not going
to look for them anymore.
It almost makes me feel
like they did it on purpose,
though, right? Like, you see the arrow,
you're like, oh, wonder what that was,
but I just treat it like a normal collectible.
I just think, like, oh, cool,
I got an arrow, you know,
like, that's gonna, I mean,
I read the manual and I knew what it signified,
so I was like,
oh, I must have at least
one TNT on me
if they're gonna start me
out this way. Right,
but I was saying,
like, you know,
if they show you the arrow
and then in the very next stage
after you progress, it says arrows reveal secrets
or something, something to that effect,
that means, that leads you kind of curious.
You're like, oh, I guess I must have missed
a secret. However,
in that same next level,
you're in the mine cart
and the first kid you save
will actually reveal
another arrow and then it's just frustrating.
It's like, okay,
I found two of these things
and I still don't have
any TNT. Yeah.
What's going on?
Like, where, where do I get this stuff?
I'm missing out on secrets.
Very much. But apparently,
and I can't confirm this,
okay, but from what I was able
to read online,
if you do use
the secret doors, there is a chance
that later on,
you won't have
collected enough
to actually be able
to progress through
the Chamber of Kali,
waves 9 through 12.
You need,
oh, okay,
wait, what item
will you not have enough of?
Whatever, whatever collectible
I guess you need
for that port,
I don't think it's,
there's a map? I thought it was
pieces of a map.
I don't know. Oh, okay.
No, no, I'm saying, like, that would be cool,
but I don't know
what it is, but apparently
using the secret doors,
I didn't use them, apparently it will
backfire on you.
Oh. Like, the game wasn't
programmed properly
to use them.
Maybe it's like, if you use all of them
or something to that effect,
but I couldn't
confirm or deny this
because I didn't do it in my own game.
Huh. Yeah, that sounds like a problem.
Yeah. It also just sounds like a good rumor.
Yeah. A playground rumor.
Are those, like,
parchment pieces you pick up,
are those the map?
That's part of the map
for, like,
I guess, level nine
or level ten or something.
Gotcha. I guess I was just picking those up
and didn't know what they were.
Yeah. I don't think
that they're necessary
because it says,
like, there's a map room
at some point and if you have
all the pieces of the map,
then the map will be complete
in the map room, but if you don't
then the map won't be complete
in the map room. But it doesn't tell you
why that's bad? I don't,
yeah, it didn't tell you
why that's bad or, like,
if you could
complete it after that
just with an incomplete map.
I didn't get there. Okay, I think I know
at least a little bit
of what it's talking about now
because I'm pretty, because I'm pretty sure
you go into the map room
and literally just, you just get a full screen map
of, I assume, what is, like,
the last level or something.
Something like that. And it tells you,
there's things plotted on it.
I don't know, I don't know exactly what,
I guess if you're more invested
in this game and you're really, like,
getting to the end, that's helpful to you.
But you got to the map room.
I didn't get to the map room.
I didn't, I got, like,
maybe halfway through,
maybe a little more, and then I watched
the ending. So I saw,
I saw the Let's Player
get to the map room
and I was like, what the heck is this?
It's the one screen
that's totally different than anything else in the game.
But I guess it must have been
because he collected all those pieces.
So I did my due diligence here
because I remembered
seeing this rumor.
So I went back to the page
where I saw it. And the issue here, Sean,
is not related to the map.
It's actually just the fact that
that Chamber of Kali thing
I was talking about, Wave 9,
that's where,
and I don't know if anybody else
got here, but this is,
that's where, like, those dragon skull heads
pop out of the lava
and you have to,
okay, so these dragon skull heads
pop out of the lava
and you actually have to
stun them
and build a bridge
of dragon lava heads
that you can walk across.
That you can walk across. It's a 40 minute scene
in the movie where he's trying to stun
all the dragon heads.
Well, that's the thing, Joe.
So it really does take,
like, a long time because you have to wait
for the heads to spawn
in the right spot
so that you can stun them
and then walk on to the next one.
And the issue apparently is
if you don't have
enough, like,
ammo and bombs
and other things,
like, if you don't have enough
of that, if you actually run out
of that in that stage,
that's it. You can't stun them
with the whip as far as,
as far as this rumor
is concerned. So,
you just have to be
very patient and hope you cross
this bridge to make it to wave 10.
Wow. It sounds, like,
very exciting, though.
I wish I, I wish I didn't
stop early.
It does sound exciting,
but I can assure you it's frustrating
because if you watch
a gameplay of it,
um, the dragon heads
don't spawn
in the sense of,
like, oh, yeah, the player's gonna try
to build a bridge,
so we, so we should make sure
that the heads spawn
in places that the player
would want them. Instead,
it seems purely random
and you just wait for the one that's going
to lie.
Sounds like a great time.
There's also a limited
number of these
dragon heads, so if you do stun
enough of them
before, like,
completing the bridge
or you made the bridge
too long or something,
that's it.
Like, Oh, no way.
you've now failed the bridge.
Yeah, you failed building it.
Wow. No new ones will spawn.
It, it almost is a program
a limited number
that, that changes the more
you stun and then just make it
unlimited and then that also
wouldn't break the game.
I regret that I don't know
anything about programming,
but it just seems like that's like,
Yeah, I feel like it would cause major slowdown.
Yeah. Yeah, maybe.
And then, Joe,
you were talking about
the map room
and apparently what that's about
is the next wave,
wave 10, that's where
if you did complete
the map, you'd be able to now,
like, get a full picture
of this giant level
that wave 10 is
with all, like, the,
the labyrinth
and stuff like that and be able to figure
your way out of that.
Better, if you had the map.
You can still do it without the map,
but it would help a lot more
to have a map. Hmm.
Yeah, it looks like,
I mean,
I'm, I'm looking at the map
right now. I think,
I see, I mean,
there's just a bunch of little people
which I assume are enemies
and there's one X.
I assume the X
is where you need to go.
I don't know where you start from.
Wow. Maybe at the bottom
of the screen. You sound like just,
you sound just like Indiana Jones
in the movie. Yeah,
yeah, right. He's with this,
that whole scene where he's,
where he's interpreting
the map. Yeah,
these look like little people.
Yeah. Um,
so yeah, I, I don't know.
I, again, maybe once,
once you're a little more well-versed
in this game, maybe this map
is very helpful,
but I almost feel like
I wonder how much
more it does for you than just kind of
trying to, just exploring.
I guess if you know,
if you know where the exit is,
that's great. I just need to know
where I start because you kind of
start in the middle of the screen.
So, huh?
I feel like my
recommendation is
if you get all the
way, if you're willing to
get all the way to wave nine,
right? The, the second part of
the game, if you will, the first eight levels
are very much the
same thing, just different layouts
and stuff like that, but you're collecting
kids, you're collecting,
uh, collecting different
weapons and ammo
and stuff like that. And you're trying to
find the key to get to the next wave.
You're always collecting anyway.
Point being that if
you're willing to do all of that,
you might as well just keep collecting the
map too and doing all
the other stuff because there's a ton of like
little secrets in this
game and little things
to find like the map
and the idol and shit
like that. But you know,
I don't know. I just wasn't compelled
to do it. And I guess that's why
I didn't also feel
compelled to complete
the game, but it does seem like
there is reward for
people who are willing to put time into
this game. I just worry that we
haven't, uh,
established enough
how horrible it feels
to play this game
sometimes. And that's why,
like, cause on paper,
it's an interesting
game with collectibles,
secret passages. You are Indiana Jones
exploring a cave with
like what later
reveals itself to be
a labyrinth and
Shankara stones and,
um, and a hidden idol.
And then you have to like climb up these
cliffs. Like all sounds cool
to me, but if the actual
gameplay is confusing
from both a graphical,
a perspective,
a, uh,
mechanics, uh,
the fact that like your whip is not
that great and that
you're, the enemies just get
like stunned into
oblivion, but they always
respawn anyway. So you just kind of
have to figure out how to get through the
levels as fast as you
want. And you put all that
together. I'm not sure if I
would encourage anybody to be like,
yeah, you should get all those map pieces to
make sure that by the time you get to wave
10, you know,
like a good player
would probably be like two hours,
three hours into this game.
By the time you get there, that's when things
really pick up and get interesting.
Yeah. I mean, I,
I kind of agree with
what you're saying, especially your point
about like on paper
it looking better than,
than it is to play.
Because like I said, when I,
once I put this game down and started
watching a video, when I was watching
the video, I was like, this actually looks
all right. Like I kind of,
I kind of want to, maybe I'll give it
another try. Started playing it again
and it still didn't,
still wasn't fun to
play. So I don't know what
I thought was going to change,
but you know,
there's some interesting
environments. There's a little feeling
of progression. Granted,
it gets a little samey,
but, but I feel like it
should be more fun
than it is. It just somehow
fails. I think they really
needed to work out
the, the perspective
and the graphics
first. I,
I know that's weird
to say about an NES,
a mental boundary
for me to like
want to continue
to work with a game
that didn't necessarily
want to play.
I feel like if they had just made it
like a, uh,
a head on like 2d
platformer, it would have worked
a lot better for them.
Definitely. And especially if now
in the context of
thinking about this map,
if you look at this map,
it's just a 2d map.
Like you don't see any, you don't see any
like elevation change.
Then when you get there,
it's, there's all kinds
of ladders and platforms and whatnot.
Like, especially the minecarts
thing. I feel like that
could have been really cool.
Like when I think about Donkey Kong
Country and the minecarts in there,
that's like some of
those are some of my favorite levels.
But, you know,
and the fact that you can like shift
your weight to
change tracks and
everything. But I,
I feel like those
mechanics are cool
by themselves, but it just doesn't
work in the game.
And that they have a
couple of things that are like that.
Totally. Joe,
you have an interesting anecdote
about the,
uh, the finale of the
game, the final level
against, uh,
Mola Ram. Yeah,
so my, my funny played
Crash Bandicoot 2.
It was giving me very similar vibes
to the final boss in Crash Bandicoot 2,
which I love Crash
Bandicoot 2, but the final boss,
you don't really fight him.
You just have to like catch up to
him. And that's kind of
what the final boss seems to be in this
is just, he's running across
a bridge and you,
you just got to run after him.
And when you get him, I,
I assume that's all
that there is to it. you win.
And it says you win.
Is it the end?
Is there any cutscene
after or is it?
There is. Okay.
You get to, you get to see,
um, short round.
Remember? No,
no, just short round. The kid that,
Joe reminded me as the,
oh yeah, you wouldn't know,
Sean. Um, not that I would know
either because Joe
reminded me before the
episode that,
uh, he's like the,
the child star of
the movie. He's in the Yankee
here, right? And,
yeah. Yes.
Yeah. Um,
and also, yeah,
he's the kid on the cover. That's a good way to put
it. Yeah. Okay.
Cause he is. And also,
uh, I don't know. Did Indy have a
girlfriend? Probably.
Cause somebody, she was different in this
one than she was in the first one.
It was different, a different person,
but got it. She's jumping for joy and
she gives you like a kiss and short round
watches intently.
And then it just says
you win big man.
Big man. Which I think,
I think short round calls
him big guy in the movie.
I think that's like a
thing. Is this the big man from
that game? Yeah.
Oh my God. Indiana Jones is the big
man from, what was it?
That karate. Kung fu.
Yeah. Who stole,
uh, Sylvia. And that must be Sylvia
there. That,
there we go. So this was actually a
sequel to Kung fu.
It's a prequel. He's stealing Sylvia.
Now I believe in the
movie, Indy actually like cut the
rope bridge while both
him and Mulleram were on
it. And then he has to like
climb up the,
the, the rest of the rope
bridge to like survive.
That would have been cool
if they would have found a way to incorporate that.
Yeah. Like track and field style.
You gotta get like, you gotta do some like
climbing mini game.
Oh, you know what? It's funny though.
Cause I'm watching the ending and they totally did
just incorporate that.
I'm watching it in real time
and they do actually have
you like climb up.
Oh, that's right. But I,
you don't know that it's up
because what's the difference in this game?
Yeah. You can't tell.
I thought you were just going that way.
The same as walking.
So cause up is straight
and left is down.
And there are like snakes
crawling around on what I
guess is the wall next to
you. So it looks like the floor
and I don't know.
Well, he hates snakes.
That's true. So I meant to bring this
up a long time ago
because Sam referenced it
and I thought it was really funny.
But Sam, when you brought up
super pitfall,
okay, I have that in my notes
here of like,
this game reminds me of
super pitfall. and then I have nothing
else. I was supposed to just
expand on, I was just supposed to
expand on that. But yes,
it does remind me of
super, if you recall,
super pitfall was also
a terrible drag of a
game to play in,
in the actual mechanics
of the character you
play as. Fun world,
definitely down for it,
but it just didn't bring
it when it came to
actually controlling the
character you're supposed to be. I think that the common
denominator between the
two of them is that they
both live in the jank
folder. Although,
now that I think about it,
Sam, I do believe you might have
been talking about
Spelunker. Spelunker?
When you were talking about the big cave game.
That's the one. I'm pretty sure it was
super pitfall,
but let me see.
Spelunker also, I mean,
Spelunker's a little bit
better than super pitfall,
but Spelunker's also a
cave game.
With bad jumping.
With bad jumping,
so yes. But super pitfall is a
game with the even worse jumping,
if you can imagine it. Spelunker have worse
jumps than ice climbers.
That's all I'm going to say. I'll just leave it at
that. We haven't talked about
ice climber in a while.
Yeah, we're overdue for another
ice climber episode.
We're overdue for an
open-world ice climber
game. Yeah, it's true.
Thank you. Thank you.
It's just important to note that in the arcade version, and I cannot confirm this because
I was not going to seek one out, you are unable to jump in the arcade version.
Is it the same game minus the jump?
It's not really the same game, but it's on the same ideas.
Because I can't imagine paying a quarter for five minutes of this.
It was definitely the same thing of rescuing kids and getting things and moving on to
the next wave and stuff like that.
The graphics were really good, though, for what it's worth.
Collecting kids, yes.
Which give you points.
So that's all I wanted to mention.
I just want to throw it out there for anybody curious.
If you want to imagine what this game is like without a jump, apparently the arcade version
has that for you.
Wow. You know, this game is really interesting, though, because it fits two different NES criteria
for us. It fits the based on a successful licensed property and also apparently a very successful
arcade game that then gets ported to the NES and stinks.
So this is the first time we've had like one of those fulfill two of those.
Such a pedigree and such a disappointment.
At the same time, absolutely.
If I can do sequels and spinoffs, as you can imagine, Indiana Jones has many games that we
are not about to just go through right now.
So I just pick some ones that I think are interesting and you guys can comment as you
feel necessary. OK, Raiders of the Lost Ark is the first Indiana Jones video game.
It came out on the Atari 2600.
It was very popular.
Not nothing really all that interesting about it.
So let's get on to the weird ones.
All right. The Young Indiana Jones Chronicle.
OK, based on that short lived TV show that apparently happened on like NBC or something
like that, like a young Indiana Jones and what he did or what his kid did or what somebody
who just wanted to also name themselves Indiana Jones did.
I don't know. I didn't watch it.
But it follows the short lived TV show.
It was made by Jaleco.
So we have another one from them or Jaleco, you know, whichever way you want to say it.
I prefer Jaleco.
And we will play that.
We'll play that on the NES guys.
That's an NES game.
So you're not done.
1990. OK.
So the Young Indiana Jones Chronicles.
Then Indiana Jones and his desktop adventures.
I just hate the sound of that title.
Yeah, it sounds so like business.
Sounds like corporate.
It's like, you know, I kind of like it.
You know how the movies are all about?
Like Indiana Jones is this college archaeology, like history professor, and he goes off on
these crazy adventures.
This game is like the rest of the time where he's just like at his desk at college.
Well, finally, we're filling in those gaps.
What it made me think of is, you know, those like shitty programs from like Windows 98 era
that it would let you like destroy your desktop.
Oh, I love that stuff.
You could use like guns and bombs.
But I'm thinking it's that, but with an Indiana Jones.
I would love that.
That would be essential in a heartbeat.
I thought it was just like something that's like an icon next to like Solitaire and what
Minesweep on your desktop.
It's also like the Indiana Jones game.
It's like a little arcade game.
And you just climb up like your desktop icons and stuff.
That'd be sick.
It's one of those games you get in like a trick cereal box.
It comes with a CD-ROM inside and you put it in and then you play.
You get a virus.
From General Mills himself.
Like the Bionicle games.
Indiana Jones and his desktop adventures is set in mid-1930s Mexico.
Indy and Marcus Brody have set up headquarters in the small town of Lucasio.
And now they are conducting excavations at Site R.
I don't know if I'm supposed to know what that means, but I'm reading it.
Site R. Yep.
Whereupon they are immediately confronted with a series of mysteries, emergencies, and adventures.
I wonder if it's supposed to be like Roswell or something.
Very desktop. I don't know what it was supposed to be, but all I know is that the game is now considered
Abandonware. Okay.
So it never happened.
It never happened in the...
Oh, sorry. I guess that's not true then, if that's the definition of Abandonware.
That's how it says it on this website.
But it did come out.
You just cannot find it.
Oh, okay. That does count.
All right. Okay.
Probably because it was only in trick cereal, which is not true.
That's just something I'm speculating.
And then, last but not least, Indiana Jones and the Staff of Kings for Wii and PS2.
Game takes place in 1939 and involves Indiana Jones searching for his former mentor while
competing with his rival archaeologist, Magnus, for the Staff of Moses.
I'm compelled.
Yeah. So were the Wii, I assume, was all motion controls?
I mean... Whipping things?
In the sense, as much as the Wii motion controls were, right?
I'll just mention that there's also a bunch of young Indiana Jones games.
So clearly that TV show was successful.
There's like six more.
Not all on the NES, thankfully.
But I never even heard of it before this episode.
It definitely rings a bell to me, which is weird because obviously none of us are very
big Indiana Jones. It's a person.
I did say live action from NBC.
Was I right? Yeah, you're right.
But I guess I didn't hear you say live action.
Yeah, you're thinking of James Bond Jr.
I am. I know I am now.
It was a cartoon. Yeah.
But it just makes it sound like it would be a cartoon.
And he's not really all that young.
Like, I just, I thought it would be a kid thing.
He's just like a teenager.
Teenager. Because it's not about collecting kids anymore.
Yeah. It's about collecting teenagers.
Well, we...
Well, I'm uncomfortable.
We have a collection of video games on the NES that we really like.
And we call that the Essential Games List.
All right, it's time for the Essential Games List.
Please make it quick, fellas.
What do you got? Sam.
Hey, it's Sam.
Um, this game, like I said before, it's in the gens in it.
But I don't feel like I'm having fun when I'm playing it.
Because it's just so frustrating to do anything.
And I, I don't know.
But the walking, though, is very smooth.
But stuff...
You're sticking to your guns there.
I like it. I'm not even going to fight you there anymore.
Because that's how dedicated you are.
Thank you. I appreciate that.
Joe, your vote.
Yeah, I think this game has, has things in it that have potential to create, to, to be the components of a game that I mildly like.
But then they fail to do that.
But like, you know, there's, like I said, when I'm watching it, I'm like, I'm like, oh, this looks like it could be cool.
You get to, like, these different areas.
There's cool little things where you got to build a bridge.
Which sounds kind of cool before it's explained, you know, before you notice it in depth.
But it just, yeah, the perspective, the controls, the repetitiveness in, in a, in a way that's not particularly fun because of the controls.
Just all kind of adds together and makes it a not great experience when it could have been an okay experience.
It had all that potential to be a decent experience.
So I'm going to say no.
I like how you're always hopeful, though.
Sean, what do you got?
This game has a lot of the complexity of the more recent games with, you know, like sort of a submenu sort of thing.
And like, it seems to be going along the lines of than, than, than this would have been.
But it's, it's design in terms of like the action, like the action design of this game is stuck in 1985.
Like it, it does not feel good to play in any sense, aside from, I guess, when you're just walking to the left or right for Sam.
I, I do not like this game.
I am disappointed in this game.
It is not essential.
All right. So there's zero chance that's going to make it on the list.
But I will add another vote against Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom being on the essential games list.
Because, you know, for me, the level layouts and the way that Indy controls, which is, if you think about it, 95% of the game is always, it always felt like a chore to me.
It's actually not fun to do most of what they set out to do.
But you, and I don't know if this is because we play these games for the show, but like I kept playing for a good while just because I was intrigued.
I was intrigued by what they, what they positioned on the back of the box and on the manual.
I was intrigued because I thought that it was laid out differently than the games were used to.
Face it. If this game was just like a weird Indiana Jones shmup where you just kind of walk down a cave and you just whip at the enemies, right?
Like as they come here on screen, that would be weird.
And I'd be like, oh, I've seen that before.
But we haven't really seen anything like this in terms of action adventure exploration.
So I wanted to give it a try.
I just never really liked it.
So it can't go on the list.
And it's not. You can rest easy tonight.
All fans of nostalgia, you can rest easy.
But I guess if you're a fan of Indiana Jones, you'll sleep on your stomach tonight or something because that's uncomfortable.
People don't, I don't know, not many stomach sleepers in this world.
How do you know that?
I sometimes do.
It depends on what night it is if I'm going to sleep on my stomach or my back or my side, you know?
Don't judge me.
Okay. Well, if you're a stomach sleeper, just make sure you set your alarm for 8 a.m.
on Fridays because we got brand new episodes every Friday at 8 a.m.
It's going to be a good time.
Next week, Othello.
That's right. We've all been waiting for.
The black and white piece checkers-like game.
No, not to play, but I would be down for that.
I'd be Iago in that one.
Actually, no, because that would make a sick, like, imagine if you could play Othello, the Odyssey, and the Iliad.
Well, talk about things coming out too late for the hype of their source material.
Yeah, I think this game was really hot in 1000.
Probably not that hot in 2020.
Give me one second.
Give me one second about Othello.
I think that it would be great if there were...
I mean, since you're telling me Othello was not based on the play,
it's sort of like a game about plays in which, like, you play a character in the play.
So every time it's your line, you have to type in the line from memory.
And that's like you being an actor in a play.
Yeah, and then when you're done, you're ready to just be in the play because you know what lines are.
When you're done, it plays the whole play from start to finish, and you can just watch it.
It's like a Mad Lib.
Whatever you type in will come up.
Oh, no, it doesn't let you proceed if you say it wrong.
It'll just start from the beginning.
And there's a time limit.
And you just have that Wheel of Fortune...
I was just going to say. That Wheel of Fortune line of the alphabet at the bottom.
So it'll be really fun.
Let's just do the Othello episode now.
We're almost about to because I think we're running out of things to talk about already for Othello.
So join us next week for Othello.
And the week after that for more real video games like Paperboy.
I'm Michael Esposito.
You can find Nostalgia at NostalgiaCast on Twitter.
We're always posting stuff and engagements through the roof, so you want to get in while the action's hot.
You could say that Nostalgia's Twitter is...
I mean, you could say it's lit, but I'm going to let Sean say that instead.
It's lit. What I'm going to say is there's never been a hard rule on following at NostalgiaCast.
We've never told you to hit the follow button.
We've never told you to be a follower to anybody.
So we're not going to do that tonight either.
But if you ever just see it, know that it's not illegal to press it.
It's not illegal to follow Nostalgia.
But we're not advocating for it either.
We don't need follows.
We're perfectly content.
Liking Nostalgia has been decriminalized nationwide.
Yeah, we're totally content with the three followers we have.
We love you guys.
We love all listeners.
I'm Michael Esposito. You can find me at Esposito Film on Twitter.
I have one follower, and I'll talk to that person very soon.
You know who you are.
I have one follower.